hello and welcome to part three of my
SEO tutorial this tutorial is gonna be
concerning the relationship between meta
tags and search engine optimization so
how important are these meta tags and
which ones if you don't know what meta
tags are what there is there are these
HTML tags that go within the head or the
header of your HTML documents so you
know your whole website's description
might actually literally go within your
header file and then subsequent pages
might have very specific meta tags so if
you've never seen a meta tag what I can
do is I'm gonna show you an example of
meta tags on my website and really the
only meta tag that's important these
days I mean there's a whole bunch of
them but basically in the old days
people used to use the meta keywords tag
and just slap in like a hundred keywords
into there and argue about whether they
should be space delimited or delimited
or comma or whatever but nowadays Google
has come right out and explicitly said
that they don't even read the meta
keywords so there is absolutely no point
to them so don't even bother with meta
keywords but what is important is the
meta description so what Google does
with this Meta Description is they'll
use that meta description whenever they
deem it appropriate in the search
results basically if they don't think
they've got a better bit of text to use
now at least in my experience I found
this to be a pretty common occurrence
for them to use the meta description so
I definitely do think it's in your best
interest to use it because you can write
exactly what you want it to say now keep
in mind it's a description so you're not
just gonna you don't want to like throw
in a bunch of keywords here you want to
actually describe your website and be
really short usually the if if the whole
thing fits in underneath like the Google
search result it
usually has a better click-through rate
but we can talk more about that kind of
stuff later so what I'd like to do is
show you guys the meta tag so you can
right-click on any page view the source
and you should be able to see
immediately we've got a meta meta name
equals description content and then here
is basically the meta description here
from my website so sentiment analysis
and opinion mining just a couple of
quick things right off the bat and then
it just explains what sentiment analysis
is so anyway as you can see it's very
short and even this one doesn't fit into
the whole description so keep that in
mind I mean you'd really need to stop it
probably like right here
it's good to fit but it can be
beneficial to do that the other thing
you'll notice is a lot it's not a meta
tag but it's a tag that goes in your
head or and that's the title of the page
right here so you this one it's just
syntax but if I go to another page like
free stock analysis or something the
title of this page is free stock
analysis right and so it goes there
it'll be in the title tags as well free
stock analysis and then you know for
scent decks but so that can be
beneficial too and it is going to read
those titles so it's important to use
the title as a really really short
description of what's in there but you
definitely want to use them now just one
quick note to make is like syntax is a
WordPress website now a lot of people
still kind of have sour taste in their
mouth when it comes to WordPress
I took a while to even get into
WordPress while I was never much of a
blogger so I never really used it but
pretty quickly WordPress kind of changed
into a all-encompassing website machine
so it's actually really useful to use in
WordPress basically immediately does a
lot of things automatically that are
really good for search engine
optimization so there's a lot of things
you don't even have to worry about when
it comes to that but things like meta
tags aren't or at least Meta Description
isn't just inherently there but if you
didn't notice
one of the things if you do have
WordPress I highly suggest you get this
Yoast WordPress SEO plugin it's very
good it's very quick and super easy to
do a lot of stuff just within here and
saves you a lot of time what rather than
like going in and editing the files
yourself by hand so anyway if you do
have a wordpress that's that and it's
still my case for WordPress I think it's
a very useful way to launch a website
now that pretty much covers the meta
tags will really just Meta Description
and then you want to have a title of a
page and the next thing I'd like to talk
about is the URLs not only what you're
gonna call your URLs but also the
structuring of your URL and so on so
that's what we're going to talk about in
the next video as always thanks for
watching thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time